I leave to here Sookie and smooth
there's why some people find this funny
stop looking at me chuan and the answer
lies in the genius of an Adam Sandler if
you're a fan of comedy chances are
you've seen at least one Adam Sandler
movie and it's not just because he's
made a lot of them whether you love him
or you hate him
Sandler has had a profound impact on the
John and until recently he was one of
the most consistent and reliable
comedians working in Hollywood his
earlier works shaped the 90s as the
Golden Age of Hollywood comedy and
helped define the genre for years to
come and although it can be said that a
majority of his films aren't exactly
great it's hard to argue that Sandler is
in watchable in fact it's what draws us
to his films not the story but his
almost suspiciously charming
performances the reason behind his charm
I think lies in Sandler's distinct
on-screen persona of course every actor
has a unique way in which they portray
themselves on-screen but none are more
exaggerated than in the genre of comedy
from Jim Carrey's physically goofy
performances to Bill Murray's dry
nonchalant with I studied 19th century
French poetry comedians rely on their
signature persona perhaps more than any
other actors it's a reason why it's so
shocking to see them more serious roles
that we're not familiar Adam Sandler is
no exception
over the years Sandler has played almost
every conceivable role from the son of
Satan to an ex-military hair stylist but
they all share the same personality that
he has honed for ages the persona of a
child
Sandler's performance as an
irresponsible and emotionally immature
manchild has more or less become his
trailer it's a persona that can be
traced all the way back to the beginning
of his career on Saturday Night Live
where he played a famous recurring
character known as canteen boy an
innocent and naive Scoutmaster who often
became the target of ridicule carte
blanche to furnish my room I see fit it
was this character among many others
that jump-started Sandler's career and
made him popular among younger audiences
eventually leading him to his first
breakout film Billy Madison in 1995
where he played a spoiled rich manchild
glad to repeat grades 1 through 12 to
prove his maturity and inherit his
father's business in a lot of ways Billy
Madison was a film made for Adam Sandler
written by himself and screenwriter Tim
Hurley whom Sandler had collaborated
with in his years at SNL the two
understood the unique charm and humor of
the childlike persona that Sandler was
great at portray and it was their
constant collaboration that led to some
of Sandler's best works such as happy
gilmore the wedding singer the waterboy
and Big Daddy but the genius of
Sandler's performance is not his
manchild persona alone after all he's
not the only modern comedian to
consistently play this type of character
it's also his unique ability of
portraying innocence and to understand
it we have to go all the way back to
where comedy began the history of using
a childlike persona for comedic effect
is as long as the history of comedy and
fun the king of comedy Charlie Chaplin
understood that a certain amount of
empathy was necessary to achieve good
comedy it's why his films often dealt
with real-world problems and issues
relevant to his time Chaplin understood
that while laughing at someone
experiencing a series of misfortune
might be suggest
there is comedy in watching it happen to
someone who doesn't quite see or
comprehended as tragic this is what made
his persona of the [ __ ] so popular and
timeless
it showed that tragedy can be
interpreted as comic depending on the
angle from which we view it it's the
same philosophy that makes Sandler's
performances so charming the ridiculous
situations that Sandler's characters
find themselves in more often than not
stemmed from real-life problems like his
grandmother's eviction notice in happy
gilmore or the abandonment of a child in
Big Daddy which by the way was clearly
inspired by Chaplin's debut feature the
kid but the characters Sandler portraits
never see these issues as misfortunes
simply because they're unable to
comprehend them the way we do but she's
an old lady I mean look at her
she's old in all his films Sandler is
essentially a child thrown into an
adult's world that he cannot understand
nor do the real adults try to understand
him a force of innocence that refuses to
change despite the obstacles he faces
interestingly enough it's the reason why
children are featured so heavily in his
films in fact quite often children are
really the only ones who understand him
and it's around children where he feels
most at home there are a lot of ways
Sandler portrays innocence but I think
it's best exemplified in moments like
this these almost random violent
outbursts are I think what makes
Sandler's personas so distinct although
they seem completely irrational
the anger that he performs is always
directed at people or things that he
finds unreasonable and unjust more often
than not it's not anger but frustration
at its inability to understand and
accept the realities around her
I think it's moments like this that make
critics describe his performances as
earnest playing a childlike character
disables any filters on his emotions
words and actions and we see the
characters for who they are warts and
all and although comedy is Sandler's
Forte it's this quality that makes him
great and more dramatic films like the
highly underrated reign over me and Paul
Thomas Anderson's punch-drunk loss which
many still regard as Sandler's best work
PT a understood Sandler's unique ability
to capture this innocence and created a
work that showcased a sense of
vulnerability that came with it once you
begin to understand the genius of Adam
Sandler it's easy to see why his career
turned out the way it did the biggest
problem I think stems from the fact that
Sandler has simply outgrown his
innocence his films portray the same
real problems that they once did we
can't do our biggest client but it's no
longer through the lens of a child but
an adult the humor that once originated
from his childlike innocence began
turning into more strangely political
and racist jokes and without any of his
former innocence the outbursts simply
come off is rude and obnoxious
it's not it's not it's not alright
alright why you get so angry why are you
so annoying it's even sadder because we
all know that Sandler is capable of
putting on a good performance his recent
works like the mirror with stories and
uncut gems are proof of it and as a fan
I miss Sandler's better comedic works
the ones that let you sit back and
simply enjoy with your friends because
as much as what differentiates Sandler
might be in his
ability to portray innocence the true
genius of Adam sample might be in
creating a work that genuinely wants you
to have a good time
[Music]